[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE PIUCCO: Hi, I'm Natalie.
And we are in the
Intelligence Neighborhood
in the Sounds and Models demo.
And I'm joined here by Yufeng.
Yufeng, tell us a little
bit about what you do
and the awesome demo
that you've created.
YUFENG GUO: Here, we have
station one gathering data.
And we have this kind of
instrument, if you will.
But it's actually
five instruments.
And so each string represents
a different instrument,
and we can pluck our strings
to make different sounds.
And what we're going
to do is use this
as our kind of data source.
The sounds are going to
then go into Dataflow
and get converted
into spectrograms.
They're going to get moved
into the frequency space.
And those images can then
be used to train our models.
The hope is that these images
will be distinct enough
to be able to--
NATALIE PIUCCO: Represent each--
YUFENG GUO: Exactly.
That we can tell
them apart, that we
can distinguish between
instrument one, two, three,
four, and five.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Cool.
OK, so we've got
our training data.
Now it's time to start
training the model.
YUFENG GUO: So with
AutoML, we can train models
using the data that we had.
But then we don't have
to do any actual work.
So we can see here that
the data is coming in.
And you can see, those are
some of the spectrograms.
Those are the real data that
attendees have generated
over the course of today.
NATALIE PIUCCO: And they're
the images of the sound waves.
YUFENG GUO: That's right.
These are the spectrograms.
And then when you train a model,
it just does the training.
There's not much kind
of work you have to do.
And when it finishes
training, you
can have some
evaluation data that
shows you the metrics around
how well the model trained
and how it did.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Right.
So if you are new to
ML, that's a great space
to get started, AutoML.
YUFENG GUO: Right.
It's an easy tool
to get going with.
And if you have
some data and you
want to throw it on ML Vision,
it'll take care of it for you.
And you can go do something
else with your time.
So we have this
board here where you
can move these kind of sliders
around to different positions.
And they map to different
values on the screen, which
change the values of
type of parameters
of the actual models, things
like kernel width and height,
the layer size, the
number of strides,
as well as the kind
of number of layers
you have [INAUDIBLE] have
to change the amount of code
on the screen.
Once we're happy with the
set of settings that we have,
we can go ahead and
push the button here
and start a training job.
And doing that,
it will assign us
a name, something
fun like spinto-cap,
and shoot that off
to Kubeflow, where we
have a pipeline to do training.
And when it finishes
training, it
will deploy it on the Cloud AI
Platform Prediction Service.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Awesome.
So time to move to stage
three of training our model.
YUFENG GUO: That's right.
Speaking of prediction.
NATALIE PIUCCO: All right.
So we're at the final
stage now, and that's
to predict the notes.
YUFENG GUO: Yes.
And so we're going to
try to pull up the model
that we've been
training, spinto-cap.
It's there for us.
So you can turn the
crank as a selector,
and then press the red
button to select it.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Select.
YUFENG GUO: So this is kind of
like a customizable music box.
And we can choose which notes
to play on which instrument.
NATALIE PIUCCO: More xylophone.
YUFENG GUO: You can
hit the button again.
So in this countdown, then we'll
be able to turn this crank now.
And so these are the
notes that we set up.
And we're going to send those
notes off to the Cloud AI
Platform Prediction Service.
Now how did we do, right?
Was our model any good?
We chose those parameters
kind of randomly.
And so it might be good.
It might not be so good.
We'll see.
It got some of them.
It seemed like it might have
actually missed a bunch.
It did.
And so, you know, this is
part of the machine learning
workflow.
In this particular case,
a pretty abysmal outcome.
NATALIE PIUCCO:
That's all right.
Because that's all part of
machine learning, right?
It's all part of the process.
So I think this is a perfect
demonstration to show that.
So Yufeng, thank you so
much for this demonstration.
I think it was very clear
in kind of the three
stages of what to expect when
training machine learning
models.
So thank you so much.
YUFENG GUO: My pleasure.
Thanks so much, Natalie.
NATALIE PIUCCO: And back to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]